what are your thoughts about the reason
why the ancient intelligences of plant
medicines were banned was due to their
their catalyzing of feelings of unity
which would sacrifice the economic no
yeah absolutely I mean there's like so
many trails to go down there one I think
it's the suppression of the feminine and
like the hyper masculine culture that
has basically said like the natural
world is there for us to dominate and
when there's plants talking to you or
talking to a culture and indigenous
culture saying hey you're part of
everything it's not a really popular way
of seeing or being when you're in a
system that needs to dominate so I think
that's like the primary unconscious
thing that's happening and then there's
the next layer which is here are like
religions or practices that the
indigenous people were doing and if we
can take away their culture and their
practices and and make that wrong then
we have the upper hand you know and so
there is the religious freedoms act so
there's things like the you know the
Native American church they can that can
work with peyote or San Pedro or there's
the UDV or there's you know there's
there's practices where you can work
with ayahuasca in the u.s. within the
religious freedoms Act so that's like
one safeguard the bees plants have but
for a long time I think that was a big
piece of the suppression is that it's
about culture and suppression of the
feminine and then beyond that it's like
if there's substances that are legal
that we can tax and we can get people
hooked on and that's a really great
formula or if there's substances that we
can make illegal and we can get people
hooked on them and then send them to
jail because we're trying to take a
certain population and keep them out of
the power structure those are really
good means to controlling a society so
you've got alcohol highly a
tobacco highly addictive and taxable and
so that's a really good reason why a
government might want to keep that those
two industries really strong and then
you've got things like heroin or cocaine
and as a government you might want to
keep those strong so that you can choose
populations that you want to keep out of
society and send them to jail whereas so
I mean I'm giving you kind of a broad I
love it
keep going and then you've got
psychedelics which which are actually
like a liberation of the psyche and
aren't addictive in the same ways and so
you know like those are the ones that
you want to put into Schedule one say
that they have no healing value and and
there you have it because it breaks down
the system of your control whoa